what it feels wrong saying that that  sounds really dirty but also interesting  at the same time fake what it's real  pick up up up up I can't imagine putting  cakehole on my face moist and ready  I hope it's fake real  oh I would not want to wear that  definitely fake underwear it's a blow  job  that's real it sounds a good I'll polish  yes it has to be real that's like I'm  amazing me that sounds real globe jobs  are so much better than the real thing  that's my life so I'm gonna go with real  on that one real use protection I mean  that's just the thing people say so I  don't think it's an actual friend I do  not agree with this I would network some  chill all over my body  oh I don't know what I want to buy it  I'm gonna say fake Oh sexy I bet it  looks really wet gay ponies dancing in  the snow that sounds fantastic that  sounds like my life I'm gonna say it's  fake  really which I was my company  what